our new series common ground highlights
people who are setting aside partisan
differences and solving problems while
common ground main it may be hard to
find in Washington it's alive and well
elsewhere in the country across the u.s.
up to 80 million acres of national
forests face the risk of a catastrophic
fire and more than 46 million homes are
in areas that could be engulfed by
flames
former Arizona Senator and CBS News
contributor Jeff Flake went to his home
state to look at an unprecedented effort
to tackle wildfires he met with unlikely
allies who are uniting to save Arizona's
forests Jeff good morning good morning
morning
Arizona's for forest restoration
initiative or for FRA is by far the
largest effort of its kind in the nation
the late Senator John McCain and I were
early supporters of the project which
spans four national forests it took
decades for various interest groups to
come together and it all began with a
devastating wildfire and an Odd Couple
pairing
still left a few trees with them
stretching almost continuously from the
Grand Canyon to New Mexico and into the
White Mountains here in eastern Arizona
this is the largest ponderosa pine
forest in the world imposing as it may
be much of it is unhealthy for nearly 20
years environmentalists Ethan amak has
worked to restore these forests he runs
the Grand Canyon trust I would represent
those who didn't have a voice well
that'd be Mexican spotted owl or other
wildlife species as Olmec puts it he
speaks for the owls
I'm the registered independent but I'm
about as left-leaning as they come on
many issues well you notice even while
we're talking I'm leaning to the right
so been very conservative grew up in a
very conservative household this is an
area that was treated david tinnies
family has owned sawmills for more than
a century and then came the timber wars
of the 1990s your family getting out of
the business was that by choice or what
happened there no absolutely not
here the fighting basically started over
the Mexican spotted owl there was an
environmental movement that was trying
to get the forest service to change the
logging practices so at that point there
was a lot of animosity in 1993 the
environmental community put forward
lawsuit suggesting that the Mexican
spotted owl needed additional
protections the courts agreed and that
logging ceased then in 2002 the rodeo
Chetta sky fire blazed across nearly
500,000 acres of Arizona's forests it
shut down the economy to the entire
region for pretty much the whole summer
it caused everybody to step back and say
wait a minute we can't do this we can't
keep doing nothing there need to be
broad community support for going back
out into the woods and doing the right
thing
no one could be left out after decades
of distrust Oh Mac and tinny and dozens
of other stakeholders started hammering
out a deal to restore the forests what
did you think whoo and you think of
people like Ethan here people on the
environmental side you know there was a
time I wouldn't give you a dynamite
to blow em all to smithereens I really
will admit what were the main
impediments from your perspective well
for us from our perspective Trust was an
impediment it was never going to go back
to the Big Timber right to the way we
knew it but it didn't have to just burn
either they agreed that the forests were
far too thick with trees and needed to
be thin so they set out to restore 200
million acres of dense national forests
we've also agreed that most of the trees
that need to be taken out or small and
that we're gonna leave the larger and
older trees as is fires burned through
these forests very frequently if there
are more trees closer together
that's right then it becomes a crown
fire which is what when you get hundreds
and sometimes thousands of trees per
acre fire will run continuously through
those trees and it's really quite
difficult usually impossible to control
that fire once it's running through it
can't be especially with with strong
winds driving it
[Music]
some industry has returned to these
woods
David teeny has left the logging
business and moved into government
he's a newly minted director of
Arizona's forestry department fact that
the two of you can sit down and sit
across the table given your background
and where you came from should that say
something to the country yeah I think it
should I trust Dave implicitly to
represent my interests in the best way
he can and vice versa and beyond that
trust we have a friendship still this is
federal land with all the bureaucracy
that entails since 2010 for FRA has only
thinned about a hundred and thirteen
thousand acres falling well short of its
annual goal of 50,000 acres we have been
supporting the Forest Service and
pressuring the Forest Service to do what
it needs to do in Washington were
obviously always consumed budget time
appropriations process and the
difficulty has been to appropriate
enough money to fight fires and still
have enough money to prevent fires
exactly the studies have shown that it's
about ten times more expensive per acre
to put out the fire than to treat the
acreage ahead of time so this this work
makes sense economically it makes sense
for the communities and make sense for
the forest for the environment it's a
win win win win win the key is that
they're working together to get to scale
and to attract more industry to the
forest something that would have been
unimaginable just a few years ago as for
the u.s. Forest Service in a statement
to CBS News it says quote it is focused
on continued work to restore the healthy
resilient landscapes and watersheds that
provide for local livelihoods and valued
products this is one example right of
where people can solve problems if they
just would agree on some things basic
principles are values that's right to
have these groups environmentalists and
the logging industry to sit down at the
same table and agree to something
substantive is Billy really something I
like what you said when when when when
when senator I'm dying to know how did
you feel about your first piece but on
the other side of the camera well it was
nice to be comfortable right in Arizona
yeah
home down so it was it was nice and you
all have been so great well done well
done I know there is more to come thank
you very much thank you